can I just go back to your other point
about the fact that um we always put it
on men so I don't agree with that
because again I did a lot of research
into this so 90 of single motherhood
it's a woman so in a single parent home
it's a woman that is the single parent
how can you say that we're always
putting it on men when women are the
ones stepping up for their kid so I'll
tell you you're right you're right 90.
90 of women are awarded custody like
I've actually talked to divorced like
lawyers about this they say they love
representing women in court it's much
easier for women than it is for men I'm
not saying it's easy either way like
court is tough but I'm saying but I'm
saying fight for it and I'm saying I'm
saying I I've actually I know someone
that went through this where he was
trying to get like custody of his
children and it's very hard because once
if he leaves the home then she can not
let him see like not let him see his
kids for say six months so with this guy
it was like she kicked him like like
like they were fighting whatever he left
so because because she wanted him out of
the house I'm gonna clarify he wanted to
be a part of his kids lives what
happened was because of covet his court
date kept moving like they kept moving
it back and what happened was she went
to court and said he hasn't been around
for eight months he hasn't been around
for a year and he'd been trying the
whole time and so it's like there's a
lot of situations where men want custody
of their children and they can't get it
and there's even men that kill
themselves because she leaves she takes
half of their his assets and he takes
the kids and he doesn't have access to
their kids like there's a whole it's
like men's rights activists you probably
never heard of them they talk about
these issues where like men there is a
guy in Ohio in the U.S
he his
um his girlfriend or whatever had a baby
and she gave the kid up for adoption he
wanted the kid he had no rights to his
kid stuff like that happens all the time
with nobody and I don't know and so when
you say when you say 90 like my thing is
like we don't think about why don't they
have access to their children and also
what would you rather let me ask you
because you got a son would you rather
leave your child with a babysitter that
is a woman or babysitter that is a man a
babysitter yeah a baby sits at 90
whatever a woman or a man I mean I would
probably prefer a woman exactly exactly
because at the end of the day this
although I understand what you're trying
to get at we can't just put it on women
and everything like that but we also
have to understand we assume we've got
different talents and Gifts okay and I
think that's kind of like what a lot of
men are trying to get at is like you
have a certain Talent which is the power
to attract which means you can get
basically any guy that you want if
you're easy enough okay so I do
understand the rhetoric of saying be
more selective because you as a woman
got way more power in your hands to
create that interaction than a man would
fine self-control take your power with
responsibility as a woman yes naturally
you will stay with your child because
you're more nurturing that's your
natural gift that still doesn't mean
that a woman is to be excused by it for
everything again for the sake of
argument right here and also because
you've put me in this position where I
actually want to stand against you I
will say men and women both are equally
entitled to complain about what is going
on because both are messing up a lot of
women they are not fit to take care of
their children but because of the
bitterness and anger they have towards
the relationship that didn't work out
they made their child suffer they take
advantage of the fact that they're a
woman and they mark their man that is
not okay there's a there's and like
women let's just be honest like women
are spiteful when they hate a man they
hate and I'm not saying all women I'm
not saying every person does this but
it's like women will use the kids as a
pawn and what what happens is a lot of
times even Kanye that happened in front
of us he he his his um another thing
they'll do is they can move States and
the father has no say if they gave the
woman's like primary custody
um and I'm not saying like I know all
the ins and outs of the laws this is
just like from talking to divorce
attorneys and it's like
um it's just like men their issues are
not brought to the Forefront and it's
really sad that like you know a lot of
times a big issue is men committing
suicide after divorce there is a guy
um I just learned this the other day so
I'm probably gonna butcher it but our
whole job most of the domestic violence
laws are based off of a system that
automatically assumes that the woman's
the victim and then the U.S and so it's
like a lot of men like most when you
talk to people that have actually worked
in domestic violence most domestic
violence situations are mutually abusive
where the man and the woman are hitting
each other and and the men still get put
away and the women don't a woman can
just call the cops and like uh a cop can
come will come in and automatically
based on their training assume that the
woman's the victim okay wait uh again
advocate for women that go through these
situations
I don't know what the stats tell you I
don't know what the stats are not
telling you because these things you
cannot actually regulate because a lot
of things go it's from um can I just
just to give you perspective it's from
people that work with these couples and
that work at women's shelters will tell
you this so much so much so much so that
they're like there is um the three
feminists that came up with the the
system that the justice and I'm
butchering this but it's like the system
that the justice system is built on that
automatically assumes the woman's the
victim they were saying that even in
their practice it wasn't what they saw
that they were saying you know what it's
actually mutually abusive but sorry go
ahead go ahead well I was just going to
say that when it comes to domestic abuse
I believe that women are inherently more
vulnerable to be in that situation
because when a woman does commit and
this is why men get upset that women
cheat because when a woman commits to a
man she gives herself emotionally when
you attach to yourself to somebody
emotionally now you are a victim to all
of these things whereas men as undertake
very quietly quite rightly said he's got
the decision whether he wants to make it
10 out of 10 happy or 5 out of 10 happy
and keep you crying here and there
because it is true that when Once men
get a woman to fall in love with them
they've got the power that's also what
men don't understand and that's how they
mess about and that's why domestic
violence I believe is so prevalent
amongst women being the vix the victims
instead of being the perpetrators
although there are cases of course the
women do take the piss and everything
but I'm saying people that like work in
these environments are saying usually
it's mutual
so like people that work like with the
couples that try to help them out
they're at women's shelters are saying
it's it's mutual yeah it becomes mutual
and this is the thing again I haven't
experienced that myself so I'm saying
I'm sorry I'm just gonna finish so be
like I'm saying it's like this is a way
that men are discriminated against if a
woman's abused there are women's
shelters everywhere there are no men's
shelters and there's all these little
things in society that once you see it
you can't unsee it where I I genuinely
believe that men are the most
discriminated against group in society
in terms of emotionally I do agree with
that just because I do think there's not
really much safe space for a lot of men
to talk about how they felt like there
was a video that went viral of Ruger it
was performing at a show and a woman
grabbed its private parts he was so like
upset by it like he couldn't perform
like he just dropped the mic and just
walked off and nothing would have
happened to that woman like to me that
is so unfair that he would probably just
think oh you know what that's a show but
he got violated
there's not a space for men to talk
about how they feel and actually what
they go through as well because we hear
about women a lot but not men so I do
agree with that in that sense but even
even and I talk about this like like a
lot of times women were just like bailed
out of bad decisions we make and it's
like if if we're if you're bad with
money and you get homeless you have a
women's shelter men are just homeless I
went there's a homeless shelter down the
street I want to do an interview there
like 90 of the homeless people there are
men but it's like nobody cares unless
it's a woman you know there was um
I can't remember it was somewhere in the
Middle East there was a group of women
that were like kidnapped and it was like
National headlines or whatever there was
a group of men that were kidnapped and
slaughtered and they didn't even talk
about it's like they only care when it's
women it's like once you and when I
first heard this stuff I was like no but
then once you see it it's like you can't
unsee it no but men are I think that I
understand what you're saying but
because men have so much power in
society if a man is homeless it'll be
like you have so much power like what
percent of what percent of men have
power that's like me saying that's like
me saying Okay
um
like when they when they say oh you can
get flown out to Dubai and all this
stuff and I'm like
a lot of girls I'm like I've never been
offered anything like I'm an offered
[ __ ] like like and it's an even smaller
percent it's like two one percent of men
that really like the workplace so right
because women have to take maternity
leave already they are already but you
have the choice
but you can't remember you could choose
to be a boss you could choose not to
have kids and under 30 a lot of women
are out earning men in cities as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible